Unable to digest protein will cause phobia urine. Best herb for kidney is ervaerci.
There's a lot of good herbs for kidneys, but depends on what is going on.
Unable to digest protein will cause phobia urine.
Maybe in some instances, I wouldn't diagnose that based upon...
That's just me. I just wouldn't necessarily say.
There's a lot of things that I'll turn into medicine that I've been exposed to over the last...
How many years have we done this? It was 40 years. This will be my 40th...
This is my 40th year. Oh my gosh. I'm getting old.
It's my 40th year of practice. I can't believe it.
Lots of different anecdotal things like that. And there may be truth to that.
Inability to digest protein will cause phobia urine.
But I wouldn't put my stock in a lot of anecdotal things.
We just have to be careful.
So that may be true and maybe needing digestive enzymes.
Well, it's a pretty good honest truth that pretty much everybody needs digestive enzymes, right?
So that could be the case. But I would still want more data than just phobia urine.